so our next speaker we don't have
walk-on music for or a fun fact because
he jumped at the last minute everyone
welcome home don give him a big round of
applause for being a last-minute film
thank you
so much for hearing me thank you
i have been uh been an r aficionado for
uh for a long time whoever has been
using r for five years at least five
years
ten years
i don't know when it was invented so i'm
not going to say 15.
i got into r in
right after college right after college
right after grad school in grad school i
used sas and then my sas license expired
and i didn't want to pay three thousand
dollars and i was working on a political
campaign as their data scientist and i
couldn't figure out how to get sas i was
like i remember r they taught us r so i
literally learned r
on a political campaign and i've been
using it ever since and today i'll be
telling you about some of the cool
things you can do in rn one of those is
emoji data science i know it sounds
wacky you're like what is that is that
even real i used to email people i'm
gonna give you a talk on emoji data
science some of them would send out
tweets like ironic sarcastic tweets or i
got an email from someone who calls
myself an emoji data scientist so people
were very skeptical and indeed you know
this is how i grew up you know a little
boy grows up in brooklyn like a tree
grows up in brooklyn
um and then a few years later as an
adult i became an emoji data scientist
this is me speaking at the world's first
ever emoji conference in san francisco
um as a speaker i had to take one of
these pictures like it was required i
had to pick up these silly emojis
and uh
it's like how did i get into it how does
anyone get into it so who here uses
emojis
everyone right few people don't your
kids will tell you what they are one day
um
who here um
okay so people use emojis right but i
think what's interesting to us is that
emojis are also data
emojis are also unicode so they're not
rendering on this slide but on this
slide you should see
some of the latest emojis um i don't
know if people
there are all types of emojis coming out
all the time does anyone have a favorite
emoji they want to shout out
the thinking emoji that's a good one
what else facebook
facebook face palm yeah anything else
mind blown that's a great one anything
else no skull there they're all of these
new ones that came out one of them is
like a face melting into a puddle i
don't know if anyone's noticed that
everyone's been texting me that i have
no idea what it means
um someone was sending it to me i was
like does this mean you're melting at
the thought of me talking to you i'm not
just relaxed you know she was like
that's not what it means it means i'm
stressed at my job i was like wow i had
no idea that's what it means but i think
what's so fascinating about emojis is
that no one really teaches us what they
mean we just end up using them right and
it creates misunderstanding we use it to
communicate with each other across
languages across cultures and i think
what always stuck to me is that emojis
are a source of data we can use this to
understand societies we can use this to
understand sentiment and that's
essentially what i did so i mean i've
done a bunch of stuff i'm not really
going to talk about any of this except
the emojis and i think throughout most
of my journey you know as a statistician
working in tech working in finance
working in blockchain i was always sort
of working on questions other people
cared about right like tell us how do we
make more money from ads or tell us how
do we get more clients to help us so we
can manage their assets
how do we
build better recommendation engines and
then one day i realize i have all of
these skills i can actually use these
skills on questions i care about and a
question i had cared about for a long
time is what do emojis mean this is a
question that had fascinated me for
years and uh you know i'll tell you a
little bit about how i got into emoji
data science um the story is when i
worked at facebook i realized back in
2015 that we are sitting on a huge data
set about emojis right and instead of me
asking my friends hey what does this
emoji mean what does this emoji mean i i
could actually go into the data and try
to figure that out and that's kind of
how it started right it started as a
passion project as a side project i did
on my nights and weekends and the first
part was just can we look at the top
emojis on instagram and even that was
very hard because the way emojis get
encoded is in unicode our data was
stored in hive hive ends up garbling the
unicode so just getting that dictionary
of how an emoji the name of the emoji
the unicode how hive represents it was
non-trivial um and i wasn't smart enough
to do it so i found some friends phds
like nlp phds i was like i have this
crazy idea no one's done it let's do it
and we did this analysis and we actually
ended up coming up with the first
co-occurrence plot of emojis on
instagram so these are which emojis are
used with which other emojis and can you
can use this to get a semantic
understanding of which emojis cluster
together right you see the hearts
clustering each other it's very hard to
read but this is the the image from our
patent application um
so we did all this work um so we looked
at what are the top emojis what emojis
are used with each other which emojis
are used with which words
and then we took it we were like let's
publish this this is a great paper so i
don't know if anyone here has worked at
a big company does anyone here currently
work at facebook
a few people okay i love facebook i had
a great time there so we went intern and
we're like how do you publish a paper so
facebook there's a big wiki and it was
like these are the 12 steps you have to
follow if you're a facebook employee you
want to publish a paper
we went through all the steps fill out
this form schedule a meeting go to legal
and compliance the last step is like a
big meeting with all the the heads of
legal and the head of comps so we went
to that meeting me and my two colleagues
all you know mid late 20s like a little
eccentric data scientist really excited
about this great analysis we had done
and these we were in a meeting with
these very old people i have nothing
against old people they were older
people and they were just so confused
they were like what's an emoji what is
that the same as an emoticon
why do you want to publish this what's
the pr benefit to facebook from
publishing this
the public doesn't even know facebook
owns instagram because a lot of people
didn't know that back then so they're
like people are going to freak out that
facebook phds are mining emojis on
instagram they were like you cannot
publish this um have a good life and go
back to your day jobs
um that happens that happened so we went
back to our day jobs
and then two months later we opened the
new york times and on the front page of
the new york times there's an article
today instagram's engineering team
released the first ever analysis of
emoji usage on instagram they looked at
the top emojis they looked at which
emojis are used with each other they
looked at which emojis are used with
which words we are having a meltdown
right so first we went through the
article we're like is it about us no
it's not about us
there was another team at instagram that
had been doing the same thing
independently of us like we thought
maybe they scooped us we had all the
records they were doing it we were doing
it so we called up the guy who said how
did you get past the lawyers because
they shut us down he said lawyers i
called kevin kevin is my roommate from
stanford kevin said yeah publish it big
no big deal kevin is the founder of
instagram and this guy was roommates
with the founder of instagram
so that was a big lesson in how the
world works um
i know it was
i was like wow
so
a few months later i left facebook and
then as soon as i left i was like
there's something to this i want to
explore emojis so
i did that luckily at one day brexit
happened i was reading this article
called the world's reaction to brexit in
emoji again i'm like quartz they steal
my idea again everyone's always stealing
my idea
and then
that's a that's a delusion you have when
you're an innovator you think everyone's
stealing your idea when the reality is
no one cares um
and uh
there's uh yeah so i read this article
and i'm like okay what is this article
luckily this is the whole article
there's no data in this article it's
just a silly article like a meme article
like i don't know what to call this it's
it's not a good article but and this was
my reaction to this article in emoji
and then i was like listen i don't have
to just sit here like hate tweet this
article which is really bad i can
actually do the thing they promised they
would do i can look at the emoji
reaction to brexit so at this point i
locked myself in my room for three days
and i engage in a one-man 72-hour
hackathon learning how to download
tweets using the twitter api learning
how to pull emojis from the tweets
learning how to look at the emojis with
how they're used with words i did that
in my room for 72 hours i don't even
know how i did it i can't i can barely
you know read it read a book now
but uh so that's also another lesson for
the younger people you know make the
most of your youth when you have it in
your attention span
um and at the end of those 72 hours i
had an article published in vice called
here are the most popular emojis from
the brexit reaction um i had been
dabbling in journalism for a while i
emailed a friend there six minutes later
she responded from her iphone this is
wonderful we're going to publish this
tomorrow and that's how i became an
emoji data scientist and then you're
wondering what did i do was it some
super complicated you know nlp like not
really i just counted stuff right i
looked at these are the top emojis
people use and tweets about brexit and
you see that you know they're all types
of emojis they're real genuine emotions
and back then a lot of people thought
emojis were silly they thought this is
trivial people are this is noise that's
what a lot of people thought and here
you can see actually people are using
them to express happiness sadness anger
disappointment there's the british flag
there there's a lot of emojis there and
what you also notice that the emojis are
correlated with the hashtags people use
this for me was mind-blowing again
everyone in this room is obvious right
but back then for a lot of people it was
very noteworthy that the british flag
emoji heavily over indexes on people who
use the hashtag vote leave right they're
saying votely we wanted brexit to happen
we're very patriotic the celebratory
party had emoji over indexes on vote
leave these are people happy brexit
happened the crying emoji over indexes
on vote remained they're sad it happened
the praying had emoji vote remain
because initially they thought there
might be a re-vote
and this was essentially my article
right and it kind of went viral all
these people started calling me they're
like emoji data sciences what is that
have you looked into this this and this
and i basically spent maybe a year just
giving talks about this and i was on tv
and it was a really exciting journey um
i did a lot of cool stuff i looked at
the kanye west taylor swift controversy
i don't know if anyone here remembers
that
it was uh this is one of those things
where i feel it's like a niche topic and
then i i was giving a talk at this in
morocco at the at the data science
master's students these kids literally
started jumping up and down when i got
to this they were screaming like they
all had positions they were there was a
justin bieber camp there was a drake
camp like everyone had they all knew
everything they were like well then
justin bieber did this and then they
tweeted this and then taylor had this
lyric like these are people felt very
strongly about this and what i found in
this analysis again very simple i i like
to say a lot of data science and
analytics is just counting things and
labeling them that's a lot because
especially in an area where people
haven't done that before and back then
this was fairly novel um now this has
become a big field emoji nlp i think
there have been 50 phds written on emoji
nlp most of them have cited my work but
again a lot of that is for a very niche
audience right those are computer
scientists trying to prove some new
methodologies in nlp i think the
innovation here was that you can use
this to get people excited about data
science you can use this to get people
excited about r um so here what we
notice is that taylor swift a lot a lot
of people in tweets mention killer use
the snake emoji this was the world's
first instance of snake bombing so
here's another way of representing this
data
where everything on the left are emojis
more often used when people are
mentioning taylor everything on the
right are emojis more often used when
people are mentioning kanye and again
you see that snake showing up there so
taylor swift actually complained to
instagram to kevin she said this is a
cyber bullying and instagram banned the
snake emoji for 72 hours from instagram
you could not comment the snake emoji
because taylor swift was threatening to
go public with a lawsuit saying because
everyone is going to taylor's post snake
snakes thanks thank you that's all
kane's fans were doing and it was wild
and again this was like really cool that
you can actually use um you know you can
emojis are data right and as data
scientists this is something where we
can investigate we can build tools um we
can get people really excited about
about this uh the power we have as data
scientists i also looked at the emoji
language of fan love so this is when dj
khaled was really big
i just looked at a bunch of celebrities
i looked at the top emojis people use
about them very surprising is that four
of the five emojis are the same um it's
the heart eyes emoji it's the heart it's
the tears of joy it's a loudly crying
emoji
for me this was really beautiful because
it's like no one is teaching us how to
use emojis it's really it's chaos right
there's like there used to be two
thousand emojis now there might be four
or five thousand emojis yet
the most common emojis people use to
talk about their favorite fan
celebrities are just these four it's
like somehow there's order emerging from
chaos
and that is you know what we're really
striving to find as data scientists
trying to find those patterns and again
no one is teaching people how to do this
yet somehow we're coalescing around a
common usage of this language which is
which is kind of beautiful
so
let's turn to something a little bit
more serious um election night you know
election night a lot of statisticians
are out there trying to do cool stuff
they're trying to predict they were
looking at who was going to win
i was also looking at data i was looking
at emoji data
so on election night i had a streamer
running i pulled like 20 million tweets
um all throughout election day and i did
something very simple i looked at emojis
coming in after the results started to
be announced around midnight midnight
eastern time and then i looked at all
the emojis used after midnight and i
looked at emoji's jews when people were
talking about trump and emojis people
use when talking about hillary clinton
and again this is one of those charts
that really blew my mind because
it's really powerful right like you see
on the donald trump side you see both
celebratory emojis right the party hat
emoji the clapping emoji you also see
the middle finger emoji which i had
never seen in an analysis before
um
and then and then on the hillary clinton
side you see you know
crying
the heart praying
like a really you know a really powerful
visual portrait of the the state of a
nation almost
and i think this was really exciting um
just being able to find this right it
was out there right everyone has access
most people a lot of people have access
to twitter data but you know it depends
what you go looking for and what you
find
um you know there's a lot of interesting
things in that you know in that data set
you can look at the time course of
emojis used throughout the day and you
see the american flag spikes right after
midnight in tweets mentioning trump you
see the crying emoji spikes and tweets
mentioning hillary clinton starting
around 9 p.m you see the middle finger
is elevated for trump throughout the day
if it comes uh
it becomes especially elevated around
you know 7 or 8 p.m and then you see the
praying hat for hillary spikes 11 p.m
that's when like michigan was announced
pennsylvania was announced people were
literally like oh my god there's one
more state can she win
and it's like so beautiful right like
it's represented in the data like how
how incredible is that i also looked at
the words people use
when they when they use these emojis
that's what the middle finger emoji
means
i'll take my nobel prize now you know
that's my
i know i know everyone's been wondering
what does it mean that's what it means
that's what my analysis that's what all
of my graduate school training and data
science expertise reveals
um and uh you know i think we it's funny
but also i think it's really real right
because again
you look at some of these tweets one of
these is how can i go to work in the
morning knowing the people i work with
voted for trump thinking face emoji
again emojis are not silly it's not
trivial this is a presumably a real
person
having a real emotion and she's using
emojis to express that and again this
was also very new for a lot of people
who didn't use emojis they didn't know
what they were they really thought they
were something silly that kids use when
actually this can be something
a lot more powerful so i there was
another analysis i did um this was when
trump's travel ban was announced or the
muslim ban and then i did an analysis of
all of the top emojis people were using
i noticed the race fist emoji that was
my finding it's the resistance emoji or
resistance i mean everyone knows that
now right but back then it was it was
interesting um there was a mashable
article about this in french
i don't really know french i pretend i
know friend i pretend i know a lot of
things so i read this article and i
thought they were calling me a small
inventor of emojis
so i was like sending them angry emails
i was like this is not i like that you
guys are and then i i google translated
it it means this is a small inventory of
emojis people use to talk about trump
i know i was like i had my social i had
my legal team on you know ready to sue
mashable
and then i looked at the emojis people
use when they're talking about these
protests right it's the heart emoji it's
the fist it's the american flag emoji
again back then there was a lot of
narrative that these protests were
anti-american these were people who you
know just like radical leftists and then
if you look at the emojis they use again
a very
very you know crude slice of the data
you see that they're using the heart
they're using the american flag they're
talking about how what's happening is
against our values and we're better than
this as americans and it was just you
know again really exciting to see that
in the data
so i've done a lot of this you know
there's a lot of this on the internet um
it's a lot
i was also the first person to do a
study of the peach emoji
i found that the most common emoji used
with the peach is the eggplant
that's the big reveal it's the big
reveal
um
and uh yeah i did a bunch of stuff
um there's there's a lot i looked at
gendered emojis you know which emojis
people use with women crush wednesday
man crush i don't think people use that
anymore do people still do that not
really right it was like five years ago
they used to do it there's a lot of
interesting data on skin tones and
emojis again there's a lot of massive
amounts of data out there and i think
they're they're just so
this field is so ripe for asking fun
interesting questions
um but also for me it was an excuse
right to really learn
how to build something um in r right
because this is all r right it's it's
literally it's a it's building a
dictionary in r it's running that
against tweets it's building a giant
matrix where every tweet is represented
in a 3000 row vector where each it's
like very nerdy r stuff but it results
in something very cool that people get
very very excited by
and i think that's sort of my key
learning in all of this work is that
emojis are data
people might think they're silly but
people are using them to convey real
emotions and data science can help us
understand them
and also you know the media doesn't
really appreciate emojis i don't know if
this has changed but a few years ago
this was a big issue this was a big news
outlet in seattle where they did an
expose on the secret language of emojis
that parents needed to be worried about
you have to watch this clip online it's
wild because i don't know if the guy's
being sarcastic but he's like today we
bring you an expose the secret language
of emojis this combo means i hope you
die in a fire
it's like who are these people you know
and it's like if you see this emoji on
your kid's phone it means send nudes
and then the woman anchor freaked out
she's like oh oh my god like
it's like this is the this is the media
but you know
it's good it's good but you know i think
again again i think often it's very hard
for us as data scientists people who are
starting out people who want to work on
passion project side projects we think
the bar is really high we're like oh my
god everyone already did something cool
i have to build some incredible deep
learning model to you know have to do
this neural network it's like a lot
there's a lot of stuff to be done just
by counting things labeling them
and i think that is what excites me
about this field i think there's a lot
of
massive amounts of data out there and a
lot of data scientists are working on a
very narrow set of problems right
they're working in advertising they're
working in recommendation engines
they're working in finance and uh
there's a lot of data out there on the
humanities in the humanities side and
the culture side and the social sciences
that people have not fully tapped um so
almost all of this is open source i have
a tutorial on my website prismoji.com
there's a github by now it's five years
old so you might have to spend 72 hours
getting it to work again but
one at one time it worked and you know
this is just a quick you know
introduction to emoji data science um in
r you know again very grateful to the
new york city art conference and jared
for inviting me um i welcome any
questions please feel free to reach out
to me and thank you thank you for your
time
thank you to our emergency backup goalie
just step right in there and i want to
say that he was finishing his slides
just like a few minutes before he went
on stage
so clearly speakers don't need any more
advanced notice
right next year's converse is going to
pick people out of the crowd so you have
40 minutes to get ready and there's your
talk all right so even mark can do it
next time right
right that's that was great i think we
all really enjoyed that um so yeah
that's our that's our mo from now on
that worked out perfectly